this episode of ear biscuits is brought
to you by Squarespace the all-in-one
platform makes it fast and easy to
create your own professional website or
online portfolio you you know everyone
should have an online portfolio I do
just in case this goes south I have a
portfolio of all my work it's just the
RET half of all of our work just in case
this goes south and I have to be hired
as an individual contract just a bunch
of split screens and use it did you have
to know how to use HTML in order to make
that right no it's just like pointing
and clicking and moving it takes all the
thought out of the process
alright listen people you can try this
out and become convinced yourself
without even having to enter in a credit
card I hate it when you have to do that
and then if you change your mind you got
to cancel it first of all you're gonna
become convinced you're not going to
change your mind
the site is great and whenever you
decide to go all in you get 10% off by
using offer code R&L the squarespace.com
offer code are a and DL now it's time
for your biscuit
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we have mr. peter shukoff
known internet wide as nice peter he is
the co-creator of one of YouTube's most
popular series maybe you've heard of it
epic Rap Battles of History in our
conversation we get into clearing the
air about the fact that we released our
video entitled epic rap battle a few
months before epic Rap Battles of
History number one did we clear the air
line I discussed it we you know yeah we
I Pete also chronicles the 8 years of
struggle before gaining traction on
YouTube including performing and airport
hangars nursing homes and McDonald's
restaurants and we get into the details
of how he invented the epic Rap Battles
of History concept and how his success
nearly led to a nervous breakdown
ah so we're gonna get in that into a few
minutes but you know we've recorded this
a little bit in advance and as you are
listening to this rhett and I are both
back in our homeland of North Carolina
celebrating the holidays with our loved
ones
hope you're doing the same celebrating
the holidays of your choosing with the
people of your choosing no pressure you
know just just do what you can and we'll
do what we can and this has kind of
become our you know tradition a lot of
people when you when you live in Los
Angeles as we have done now for three
years a lot of people ask well so are
you going home for the holidays because
no one is home that's the thing that you
learn is that no one is home now here
you meet a couple of people who were
born and raised out here but the vast
majority of people go home for the
holidays and then we've heard we've
never experienced it but we have heard
that Los Angeles becomes like a ghost
town there's nobody on the road
tumbleweeds on the highway everyone just
evacuates and goes home to their
respective places across America and the
world or whatever so we and then the
elves come in so when you come back to
LA in the new year
there's wooden shoes at your at your at
your bedside for every person they leave
wooden shoes for all of the los
angelitos mmm Los Angeles mmm
Angelina's Angelina's angelitos that's
like a Taco Bell
dish dish the angelito it's a tasty one
so what are we doing right now while on
holiday Rhett well I like to take my
time when I go back home to eat at the
various places that I don't get to enjoy
because you know me I like to eat it's
one of my favorite things to do I know
you so I mean one of the things that we
do is we almost always have our first
meal at Bojangles you know famous in
consist kits and cuz there's just not
you know an interesting thing is you
have told me recently that you like
Popeyes or that you think Popeyes is
like yes well it's pretty much like
Bojangles I'm not I'm not saying I don't
like Popeyes but I don't West Coast
imitation I don't think I think that
that I don't know how they get that
stuff up under the chicken skin like
they do but it is the red stuff and they
got a new sauce yeah well it's funny
because I got a friend back you North
Carolina
be seeing while I'm back there Lance and
Lance good friend and he likes to text
Lance is the voice in the as of the
director in the first spanner commercial
we made oh he sure is yeah so he texts
me and he says things like takes me a
picture of the new sauce from bodings
like Bojangles has a special sauce fYI I
started a new job next week like it's
like you know by the way should have
just been and PS I started job is
basically the important thing is the
sauce the less important thing is the
rest of my life in my career yeah and so
I text back and like gotta try that when
we're home what's the new position so
the first thing is like yes kind of like
a tangy honey mustard and then he goes
on to describe his new position that is
new job so well and you kind of
reflected that I told you what are you
gonna do spit when you're going home
presumably the answer is well I'm linked
I'm gonna spend quality time with my
family that I haven't seen all year and
your answer is I'm going to go to
Bojangles and eat fried chicken and dip
in the new sauce I'll be with my my
parents I mean they'll be at the boat
yeah they like it - it'll be a family
affair now what about you because you
have I'll go to Bojangles - absolutely I
might see you there I sadly I have had a
lot of my family members that have
passed on I don't have a lot of people
left
you know there's pretty much just my
parents and then you know why spirits
and you know brothers and sisters that
kind of thing but you I've got ways of
living
elderly people got like a
great-great-great grandfather that's
still living 182 and all eats is bacon
that's right
no but you seriously need a lot of
people are doing pretty good and my
mom's mom nanny is doing pretty good
we're gonna spend a lot of quality time
with them let the great grandchildren
get them in the holiday spirit and your
mom has a husband and your dad has a
husband Ted has a wife right they are
not each other so you so I mean this
this is quite a situation that you go
back home to oh I'm liking I'm like an
i10 I'm like a gypsy when I go home it's
like me my wife and my three
kids and we just like itinerant move
them from house to house spend a little
bit of time here a little bit of time
it's really exhausting I'm not
complaining it's it's a blessing to have
all of these loved ones to to want to
see us but it's I mean it's exhausting
the one thing we did to help simplify
things this year I'm very excited about
is we rented a car
hmm now you know the gmm episode that I
told you it was probably last January
about how I borrowed my father-in-law's
truck and I told the whole story about
how I messed it up but you can you can I
don't I don't want to do a repeat of
that
so I've rented a car and so now we're
gonna be we don't have to go through the
logistics of car handoffs when you have
three children and there's five of you I
mean it is it's a challenge to get
picked up the airport get moved around
yeah you want to have your own
transportation it's weird when you
become excited about renting a car oh I
love her in the car I feel like I'm God
I got a new car
for a little while smells new almost
sometimes sometimes it smells like the
guy that was in there before you but
smoke now here's one questions go you're
like Bojangles when you're done with it
you go to all these different houses who
has the best food where's the best food
what cast is that at every place has
like a sucker a signature dish really
we're going to Christy's parents house
first and they mr. Bobby that's my
father-in-law he fries the shrimp that
he gets on mr. Bobby it gets from the
coast he wants me to call him mr. Bobby
so I just I don't sometimes I call him
that but I think it's kind of weird so I
don't call him anything you can just
like I just call him a hey would he be
upset if you called me Christmas I yeah
I think so you need a listen you're a 35
year old man this is this is a year this
is not about this is the year this is
when you see him shake his hand and call
him Bobby I just say it now you can do
it call him Bob I can't do it I can't do
it but they Bobby it it's not about me
if it was about me that's what I would
do but this is something that he thinks
he doesn't need to hold that over you
though a 35 year old man it's a sign of
respect he calls all the people mr. and
mrs. so-and-so
really yeah he still does well you need
to change that so it's it's respecting
your elders then so so what does he mate
what's this fine shrimp
mr. Bobby makes fried shrimp get over it
guess what well there's no getting
around it is that the best food of all
the relatives nanny makes great fried
chicken my mom makes some country-style
steaks you can that you could die for
make you want to slap your mama eggs
unless if she made it you want to slap
her unless is the thankful slap my dad
makes ribs because we only come home
once a year they all make something
that's like Maisie doesn't even have to
be related to Christmas room from me in
that rental car how big is it SUV it's
not that big you know you got you got a
car seat for me if you call me mr. link
then I'll take you anyway I'll call you
mr. linky all right let's get to mr.
nice Peters conversation his personal
channel has over 2 million subscribers
that's nice Peter but his er B channel
that he shares with epiclloyd co-creator
of the series has over 8.5 million
subscribers and this series has garnered
over 1 billion views people that's 1000
million last time I checked that's a lot
of views and it's been a lot of epic
guests on the series including Snoop
lion key and Peele it's best Snoop Dogg
and maybe somebody that you've heard of
rhettandlink rhettandlink we're on there
they played the Wright brothers freshers
the Mario Brothers remember they happen
so here we go our time with nice Peter
[Music]
feel like I'm picking a punk I feel like
the same guy but sat down on a lunch
table with you guys and the same lost
lost person so the first time we met at
the first VidCon you're having
flashbacks to that right now I've been
having flashback to that all day yeah
yeah yeah
what's your memory of our first meeting
my memory of our first meeting is I had
been watching and seeing you guys online
for a while then and I had seen I had
gone through a dark period where I
instead of aspiring or like being
inspired by people I was jealous and I
saw things and it was like why aren't I
doing that and I now look back and
realize oh because I'm
because I wasn't doing it it wasn't that
I could write I don't know what I
expected it for magically just open up
to me or something I realized I had to
create my own opportunities and create
my own work and then I could do anything
but at the time I was I was really lost
with what I was doing I was playing I
think just before a few like months or
weeks before that I had been playing a
show in Iowa and the whole front row had
their back to me and I was just like I
was trying to me I was trying so hard
but I wasn't trying hard at the right
things so I saw you guys as two guys who
are trying hard at the right things
definitely trying hard you but that's a
big difference from what I was doing you
tried you tried to have a very popular
and successful video on the internet
that focused on music and comedy and I
was wondering how come I don't have any
very popular videos in the internet that
focus on music and comedy but I wasn't
really trying to do them I was just
wondering why I wasn't doing them yeah
you had at it you had a few picture
songs that were floating out there at
that point yeah it started to gain a
little momentum and I was starting and
that's what was such a great time to
meet you guys because I was like I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do I'm gonna do
I'm gonna follow kind of this path of
just like doing great work and I saw you
guys as guys who were already doing that
and so it was just a cool time to me
well it's interesting now the tables
have turned because now we have to be
jealous of them the most successful
musical series in the history of the
Internet one of the most successful
series if not the in the history of the
Internet I think that's where maybe
where I was lucky to have all that pent
up like I free I refer to all the sudden
for me to remove my own blinder of like
the reason it's not happening so I'm not
doing it and then I was like oh my god I
gotta I gotta make up for this fast
right it's my last chance I felt there
was a lot of desperation I was like I
was really broke I was I was about to I
was about to sign up for a job valet
parking cars which no you know no one
sold to anyone the valet parks cars but
I knew that was like kind of tragic I
knew I have something better to offer
and better to do but that's just where I
was I was just desperate and I think
that desperation
was really good for me too
to finally get an opportunity and it was
it was a very fateful conversation with
Danny that changed my entire life when
tiny diamond nanodiamond uh-huh i sat
down with Danny diamond and he asked me
pretty pretty straight he was like why
aren't you successful I think you're
talented and I said well I I'm working
this job I was working like for a bakery
delivering medicinal baked goods around
town okay a lot of green Baker a little
green bakery and that was that was my
job and I had to wake up at 9:00 and
drive around till 4:00 p.m.
what was it called he kidded the Venice
cookie company baby excellent products
they made vegan medicinal cookies no one
was doing gluten-free things okay so
they didn't have marijuana at him they
did you know I'd be proven in this yeah
yeah aspirin laced they had they had
medicinal properties but they also they
tried to make a gourmet treat that
wasn't like over sugared it was like
these for people who want just the
medicine they want to eat it they don't
wanna smoke because that's bad for their
health mmm and it was guide like the
company was cool but that was what I was
doing from 9:00 a.m. to 4:00 p.m. so by
the time I got out 4:00 p.m. it was hard
to have that like extra energy reserve
to really push myself creatively so I
told that to Dana he was like all right
well that's ridiculous so I'll I'll give
you a salary that matches that and then
you won't have that so all right now I
use why aren't you successful because I
mean all the cookies because I mean all
the cookies no as I said well my you
know I my computer's it's just not I
don't have the tools that I need my
computer is not I'm not able to edit Pro
Tools is barely running it's like
alright I'll get your new computer
why aren't you successful this is a good
conversation yes and what point did you
start calling him sugar daddy I never
did we were it was a very casual stay I
barely knew the guy was at I'm like I
just joined you know I don't even know
what was called maker at that point it
was called the station to me right I
thought the fine brothers owned it and I
thought Danny was a janitor he was this
like this guy with a scraggly beard the
better
during meal sitting in the back corner
is he authorized to do exactly I didn't
I didn't I had he was so mysterious I I
didn't understand what he was and then
he was he was really revealing to me
what to me what he he does and what he
does it so different is he he sees
people he believes in things without
there's like there's nothing that's
gonna stop you there's nothing that's
gonna stop me there's nothing he's gonna
stop us everything is surmountable so
once he removed those two challenges I
said well I just feel like I need like
some exposure to people like I think I
feel like I can entertain any room that
I get up in front of if people are
listening I like that I used to go to
the post office and try to make the
grumpy back ladies at the post office
laugh because I thought they were the
hardest people to make laugh in the
world tough crowd
toughest yeah and I would go there like
I won't make these look I'm gonna crack
this lady up and I don't do it I was
like I can do this man no video cameras
no idea okay just put your you just
figuring out what what do they need to
feel entertained what what kind of what
kind of performance is gonna amuse these
ladies and that's something I developed
over the years of joy it could be a
great web series though how to amuse
grumpy black lady at the post office but
he gave you there's audience he gave me
no easy put me in in some videos that
were like just you just connected me
people connected me with casts I mean
connected me with che and he just he
just put me in front of people and he
was like all right people are watching
you got you got momentum you got your
computer you don't have that day job
why aren't you selling you know 25,000
songs a month right and I was like I
guess it's cuz of me
I guess that's you just removed
everything that isn't me I guess I'm the
only person to blame and that just did
something to me the idea I had stopped
performing live and focused only on
making videos okay I was gonna do a rap
show a live rap show with Lloyd and
another one of our writers who played
Einstein Zach cherylin and I had to pull
out of it at the last second but they
did it and one of their segments on
stage and this improvised rap show was
to get suggestions from the audience and
do a rap battle between those two people
oh wow and so you know they'd get
whatever some Winston Churchill versus
you know Marvin Gaye and and write
improvise a free
style of rap I'm not easy to do not easy
bail amazing yeah and and and they're
both pretty good freestylers so and
Lloyd came over my apartment and mean
Lloyd just used to work on music that
was something we had in common and we
were working on something maybe a rap
song of his or something he told me
about I was like how's the show going
you said uh did this segment this
segment is pretty cool we get to people
and I was like oh that's that's really
good and I I said we should we should
try some ways to lay something down
that's really cool and we we freestyle
the battle between Michael J Fox and
Chucky from from the movies and it was
horrible like just the two of you just
the two of us in my apartment and and it
was horrible it was really really bad
but but I just I was like this is so
cool and I was I was searching for every
kind of format I could mmm that was part
of my new I was determined to make good
videos and make popular videos and make
a living off of making videos and I was
like I need things that are refillable
and like picture songs are unsustainable
they're too hard to recreate I don't
know why because they're just weird
magical moments that happen but this I
was like this is cool and at maker I had
these resource days where I could get a
camera guy and a green screen and and
and get to use their production machine
I was really doing everything by myself
at home I was making all my videos in my
bedroom etc but I got to use these days
to work with their machine and I was
like I'm gonna use him on this and a
that night I I may or may not have had
some vegan cookies and I just saw this
this whole world of of taking these two
people and putting them in this Mortal
Kombat universe this like
transdimensional universe and and having
these two people from history and and
just going out and having this announcer
that announcer came from the movie
idiocracy you know in the rehabilitation
scene or he's like I haven't seen it oh
my god it's amazing and they have this
announcer and it's this otherworldly
voice that comes from nowhere and that
that I was like and it's gotta have an
announcer and um I don't know I told the
idea and we were gonna do it we were
going around to different directors and
didn't know where we're gonna go
it almost got shot like in a grimy brick
you know with like a grimy brick
background and I'm you see that not
green screened you know
and uh I I got for some reason I got
assigned to Dave from Carrie who's now
directing on Saturday Night Live which i
think is a testament to how talented he
is
and I I told him the idea and he went oh
yeah and he got it and not only did get
it but then he took it another step
further so it was like it was just this
collaboration between me Lloyd and Dave
and how did you pick the first one you
did the audience still O'Reilly yeah the
audience did that and now you you posted
a vlog where you asked people yep I
posted a vlog and I asked people I said
I didn't call it epic rap battle at that
time I went back and watched it and I
was like we're gonna do this incredible
rap battle of history so who would you
want to see and we got maybe four maybe
fifty suggestions maybe a hundred and
Bill O'Reilly burst John Lennon just
stuck I stood out for me and Lloyd I
think it was like I'm excited to play
John Lennon and Lloyd was excited to
play Bill O'Reilly and that Bill
O'Reilly freakout video was really
circulating right yeah I was like this
is it we're gonna make fun of this video
so we're referencing the Internet or
being self-aware John Lennon it's gonna
be cool and John Lennon was originally
gonna be in this in that New York City
t-shirt and I remember shaycarl was was
on Venice Beach and I called Shay I was
like hey man can you look for a New York
City t-shirt and everybody was everybody
at that time was so collaborative we
were all just so much and he touch in
touch with each other's dreams and
ambitions and aspirations all working
together and it's not it's not this it's
not the same as that anymore I don't
think I could call Shay Carl and ask him
help me find it t-shirt for a costume
I'm sure I could but it's not that
culture now well and we want to come
back to the you know what it's like to
now have this series that is so
successful and obviously it's it's all
almost all your time okay yeah it's not
but we want to go we want to come back
to that but we want to go all the way
back okay to little Peter and by that I
don't mean your Peter I mean sure young
yeah young you were born where are you
boom where were you born I was born in
Rochester New York okay it's cold there
it is cold yeah
it's cold right now but it's it's it's
all right it was it was great I lived on
a dead-end street that was nice okay
who'd you grow up with you bedded mom
and dad mom and dad I have an older
brother
um how old are five years okay uh and
that's it you and the older brother
that's it yeah mom and dad I had a
grandparents that were they were very
cool my grandma my grandparents on my
father's side from our from Russia so
they were they were cool they were
friendlier than I remember my
grandparents on my mother's side being
as a child and they lived in a
greenhouse and my mother's parents lived
in a white house so they were my green
green grandma and my white grandma
growing up that's what you call that's
what I called them and green grandma and
grandma and white grandma and I I find
it I wasn't raised with any knowledge of
race I I remember being in like first or
second grade and realizing that the fact
that the person sitting next to me was a
different color had deeper meaning than
that and I'm really grateful to my
parents and my grandmother because of
that because the rest of my family has
that weird like racism but kind of like
kind of those people kind of vibe you
know okay not not derogatory but and in
in that I'm not being fair to them
because that they've all the younger
people that generation have gotten rid
of that but my my my grandparents my
grandmother's brothers and sisters had
that classic I don't know that classic
Middle America like we're different and
for some reason I was just raised
without that completely I took a black
girl to the prom actually a black girl
took me to the prom my parents didn't
bat an eyelash at it they didn't it was
it wasn't even it they didn't even go
out of the way to say this is okay with
us it would just wasn't an issue yeah
they didn't talk about it didn't even
talk about it wasn't even weird and I'm
I'm always grateful for that
is it true once you go black you never
go back I I know that's not true I've
met your yeah it wasn't it was old
friend it wasn't true in this case but
it was white I don't know if you're
still dating her but I am yeah okay that
has been that has been tricky with with
what I do
everything's been tricky dating a white
girl dating away no but so I grew up I
grew up just with I think an open mind
and I was encouraged by my parents to be
creative and we took piano lessons and
were they musical people no hope there's
not a no there's no what do they do
they're both lawyers really yeah are
they still together yeah
yeah they're actually coming out here to
visit for
Christmas and they've never been out
really yeah never been out to visit two
lawyers married all these years yep well
there is hope in this world I know but
they thought that for whatever reason
that you should be exposed to music yeah
we had a piano or were you
self-motivated were you like I want to
learn to play but no kid says I want to
learn to play piano or I was always man
I was I was making songs on my teeth
when I was a kid I know how weird that
sounds but I would I would sit in the
car and like and just tap out my teeth
that make different pitches I can make
different pitches and I just I since I
was a kid I've been messing with
anything that makes noise to translate
things that I hear that are just simple
just little bird and button you know and
so that was something I always did I
don't I think he was all more I was more
into detention and acceptance than I was
in like musical knowledge I think I
found I felt I felt left out and strange
as a kid as a young kid for whatever
reason or for what were the reasons left
out of what school like friends yeah I
think friends and just like I don't know
I just always felt strange and I think
part of those reasons are things I'm
still discovering about myself and
things I'm still understanding things
I'm maybe not not ready to like talk
about our microphones but I just for
whatever reason I felt always different
and I felt always I'm not necessarily in
a good way I felt I felt like I didn't
belong and I felt like I didn't fit in
and I felt just uh yeah just like I felt
like everyone was gonna laugh at me or
make fun of me and so I very early on
was like I'm gonna do this on purpose so
I'm gonna if people are I'm gonna feel
comfortable feeling left out cuz I'm
just gonna turn into a thing of I'm
performing I'm I'm making people laugh
and that that way I'm controlling how
how I might get so kind of a class clown
scenario kinda are we talking grade
school yeah that young yeah yeah do you
remember anything that you did like
strip naked and run through the school
or no not really I was just always aware
I was always from I can remember being
aware at a young age of just how people
react and just like reading people and
seeing where I can push lines and
seeing where I can get laughs out of
people or get amusement out of people
get attention from people I was just
hooked on attention and I was hooked on
approval probably to a potentially
damaging level and but it is the kind of
thing that kind of propels you into it
it don't read entertainment it does I
never expected to be successful ever
I always expected myself to be the guy
that people thought well that guy could
have been something and that was
something I carried into my 30s you know
30 I'm 34 years old right now and at 31
I was that guy I was like that guy could
have been something but he kind of just
kind of fizzled up and the girl I was
dating at the time kind of was starting
to ask me questions like so what are you
really gonna do and that is
disheartening
um so even back then you had that sense
did you get in trouble a lot for being
the center of attention
talking for yeah I mean I got in trouble
with my mom a lot I I was constantly I
don't know I don't know I don't know how
to explain it I was constantly I I grew
up in an Irish dancing troupe what yeah
when I was six years old I got tricked
into joining and I arse dancing troupe
because my mother told me my cousin was
going to join it and my cousin didn't
end up joining it but this other dude
did and for two dudes in an Irish
dancing troupe is rare so more dudes
joined the Irish dancing troupe so we we
had a dude heavy Irish dancing group it
was like 12 guys and as this this is
like the dancing one that when the arms
now I was in a kilt and all like rain
dance sort of situation right River
River it's all in the legs all in the
legs and it that haunts me to this day I
can I can move my feet like James Brown
but I dance like a brick up top and so I
grew I grew up in that environment of
school was like school but then my my
life was in this Irish dancing thing and
I went to classes and that was where
that was where I felt the most like I
belong to a group and also the most left
out I felt I felt weird I don't know I
don't know why I just felt like I didn't
really belong to this group but I could
belong as long as I was funny and and so
that was that was something I just
started and they I was lucky man these
guys some of these guys had the best
laugh
the world is a guide Tim I just saw him
he's got the best laugh in the world and
I think if I hadn't been friends with
him as a as a younger kid I don't think
I'd be doing what I did today so you're
keeping in touch with the Irish dance
troupe yeah I said I think more than my
more than my high school acquaintances
they still taurine know they're all I
mean there are a lot of them have kids
and stuff but the troops are still going
so that that got I didn't have stage
fright ever because when I was eight I
was in front of my third grade class and
it killed dancing at my elementary
school yeah that all that'll knock the
dust off yeah so and I we should
abyssion I guess and all of March we
would go into nursing homes and perform
and shopping malls those good crowds
nursery we thought we had performed in a
nursing home I'm not kidding you
remember that no in the band now like
the youth group like a church thing yeah
it's good for society yes great girl I
want to do more stuff like that if like
just making people who really need to be
entertained giving them some energy
right instead of the people who you know
I don't know Darth Vader and Charlie and
yeah at a nursing home exactly I love it
so I I just didn't I didn't have stage
fright I did feel weird about myself I
was very motivated to learn how to be
funny and I kept I think I'm relatively
smart and I just kept learning about how
to entertain people at the same time
were you thinking about okay
because we talked about this just where
we're from
yeah we were being funny but we didn't
know that being funny could be a career
so there was never any oh this is what
we're gonna do for a living necessarily
it was like we're gonna get real jobs
but let's always be funny were you
thinking about what you were gonna do at
that time I don't know I was always
performing so I think so I think so cuz
then just after that you know with the
lack of stage fright and an ability to
entertain people inability to be funny
I'd started doing plays and like getting
more into it okay so I think I was
always it was oh it was the only option
for me ever and then in high school my
friend Ben he said man you gotta you've
got to do something with this you've got
like if you if I doubt if 20 years from
now I don't I don't see you on stuff I
don't see you on TV or something I just
don't know what I'll do to myself I
don't know how I feel it would be so let
down and so was that conversation with
Ben that got you off the dime it was
huge as I was in high school and it was
huge it's stuck in wrong in my head it's
allowed me to
never been able to give up because of
because of little things like that so
what did you do anything could I found
it I discovered the guitar in my junior
year in high school and still in New
York
yeah and I I went to an arts high school
a public arts high school so that was
great I got to be in musicals and plays
and I was always a I look back sometimes
it the hard time I gave our
choreographers or our directors I was
such a bossy little know-it-all and I
feel so bad but then I feel like I might
have actually known some stuff I don't
know this these instincts might have
been there and I might have known that
that piece of choreography was stupid
yeah right and it's not my place but I
still think I was right she had us
jumping up and down when we sang the
final big note of a song and it was like
we can't sing we're jumping up and down
yeah and I gave up I put up a big fuss
in front of this hole I mean who was I
to do that as a junior in high school
you didn't get your way though no you
lost I lost I was like and I thought it
was so stupid like a War Chant exactly
for a big note so I I feel like I'm
meandering a little bit playing guitar I
started playing guitar because it was a
great way to get attention and
acceptance and that I got not I'm not
gonna deny that that was my primary
motivation I was like I like to make
people laugh and I like they haven't
approved this is good for everyone
attention exchange I imagine you
immediately moving into learning Queen
covers and things like that yeah I was
just has more piano bass but it was
instantly - all right the only reason I
learned car so I could sing songs that
people liked and I wasn't even the lyric
writer I worked with another guy named
Jason he wrote all the lyrics I wrote
all the music and he was brilliant man
he was a much better writer than that
was but this was all comedic songs all
communiques and all originals originals
yeah we've been writing new originals
about what kind of stuff poop you know
masturbation right classic junior your
high school stuff yeah our first song is
called dump a dump dump it had a key
change which was I thought Oh getting
out that last Turkey yeah yeah
it was autobiographical and true is what
a real guy is what a real scenario of
poopy of pooping yeah what was this
scenario we walked Jason walked in and
there was still a poop left in the
toilet from this guy I know Christmas
was so big it was so um it was so
unbelievable that inspired this this
mythic story with a key change with a
key Chad need it was so such a big dump
it need a key change those type of songs
yeah but then you would just sing to
friend just sing a French singer
lunchroom sing to my Irish dancing
troupe and you know and and singing in
Nick is keys barn and and and just uh he
was a bit he was the best dancer in the
group
he started out I got him into it late he
came in late he quickly became the best
and now he designs buildings that are
energy if like self-sufficient that was
his thesis project it was a
self-sustaining yeah okay like connected
that Irish dance only connect Irish
teens but that was that Irish dancing
thing I got a I got to thank my mom for
tricking me into that cuz that
definitely put a serious trajectory of
my life I was performing with abandon
from a very young age in a group that
encouraged and fostered my sense of
humor mm-hmm so what was the next point
after the guitar writing the funny songs
on this trajectory of to where you are
now what was the next point on that like
what happened next that oh that's one
point you started doing stand-up I don't
know yeah I do my college I went to
college I left my guitar at home the
first year I went to college cuz I
wasn't really a songwriter I was where
what college uh state school in New York
called Fredonia it was whatever it was
whatever I think that's what their
brochures say yeah it Sonya it's
whatever whatever and I went to school I
didn't take my guitar I wasn't really
doing that I was hanging out dorms and
going to parties and not really
performing or doing anything like that
and I was gonna become a teacher I was
gonna become a history teacher and so
which I find ironic now yeah Wow and and
then sophomore year I audition for this
improv troupe and I got in and I got my
guitar back out and I started started
just performing and we had cool theater
it was once a month it was like a five
and
seat theater it was it was actually a
good college improv show and that
changed that changed my life again so
that was cool so you you you broke out
the fart songs no then I started getting
deeper with the comedy songs I'm the
first first song I wrote of this new era
in my life was about one of the cast
members was leaving and so I wrote this
really heartfelt song about her leaving
but it was funny and that's that's where
I started to discover that voice of like
talking about something whose real I
mean the poop song was even real right
yeah it had some heart that's a poop at
some pets move had some heart but now I
started I started learning how to write
songs that dealt with emotions and dealt
with feelings and and just letting a
feeling in spot and then the writing
process is so much easier than instead
of like what am I gonna write about I
was like I have to write about this I
feel so much about this I have to write
I'm gonna use my abilities in melody
construction and humor to make it more
palatable to people but it was more of
I'm listening to this musing my head and
that improv troupe yeah I the a lot of
the older members left and me and two
other members kind of became the
creative directors of it and we started
choreographing these big dance numbers
and and it was great
it was so you it was your influence that
made it more of a musical musical thing
because that's it you know when you talk
about stand-up which we want to hear
about how you did that I know that there
is a well improv you still my improv
right well when we get to get to
stand-up though you kind of carry that
into stand-up like you you're a musical
comedian is something I didn't really
know that you weren't a musician first
and then kind of made it know when you
when you started looking at music it was
for common for comedy and really but but
it was for attention and an approval and
when someone laughs you know they liked
it you know you did you know you did it
right I don't have the balls to to take
silence as approval and like that was
really good man
that's not enough for me I'm too hooked
on like hahaha okay I know you like this
I can keep going
keeps me fueled it keeps me you know
feeling good so what about after college
after college opt out of college and the
improv troupe the guy who started that
was gonna start an improv theatre out in
Long Island in Riverhead Long Island
which if anyone is familiar Riverhead
Long Island it's a
so you had not been there you thought
this was like coming out to check it out
I was like this is great this perfect is
I thought house for 14 people I live in
a room with two other guys it's a dream
I was like a commune it was a common it
was an improv commune the theater when I
was there never got off the ground and I
spent one summer there I learned how to
wait tables I learned that was that I
don't know if you ever had that
depressing stretch in your life where
you really learn guitar you know there's
nothing else to do see really learn how
to play the blues kind of thing you
learned how to play just stuff you
actually sit down new charts and new
chords and new fingerings and like take
your skills a step up instead of just
like doodlee doodlee doodlee doodlee got
it I had been noodling I learned I
learned Weezer's Blue Album that was
obviously very influential on me I
learned just I just learned how to play
the guitar and I don't think I got much
better since then now right you made a
choice to drop out of college in order
to do this what did the parents say I
called my I called my parents I was on
acid when I told them that I was
dropping out of college I don't know if
that's something I should say Thank You
familias literally does that make it
easier no I was just already that just
shows how seriously I was taking school
I was just not I was failing out of
school miserably the only guy would let
me get away with anything was my history
teacher and I think I don't know why I
think is if we had nice conversations if
I would show up to class but I was just
failing everything I had a 1.67
GPA which I don't got a low rule oh I
think it takes extra effort at Fredonia
yeah and-and-and Fredonia's not exactly
a place where people excel anyway so I
was just really doing bad and so you're
taking a lot of acid
no or notice occasionally I was smoking
a lot of pot I'm smoking a lot him and
then the occasional my acid I'm sorry
it's my story
right well I'm trying to I that's the
other things I felt like I used to be
much more honest about talking about all
this kind of stuff and when I started
making YouTube videos I felt this
responsibility that there were a lot of
younger people watching me and I felt
like I can't talk about this kind of
stuff well I mean we want to hear the
real story here and I think people
appreciate the real story of where you
came from okay you don't people don't
want to draw conclusions about the
the sensor story alright well I was
doing a lot of drugs and I wasn't I was
I was doing a lot of drugs and like
staying in my room a lot and like just
just putting everything off I was just
like looking at a lot of porn and
smoking a lot of weed and not really not
challenging myself not pushing myself
and and so the opportunity to do so all
I cared about was performing I didn't
care about school so I just dropped out
and went to go perform and then I've had
a pretty good track record of okay so I
want to go back to the conversation with
your parents what was the what was it
like in that moment talking to your
parents did it make it like this is not
really happening or kind of and I've
kind of been in that days ever since of
just not this is not really happening it
makes it hard it makes easier for me to
deal with reality if it's just a little
askew acid is just ending it just
encourages you to relax your guidelines
of what's real and what's not
and then you could sit here and imagine
that bass walking across the room and
even see it in your brain you could
watch it walk across the room but you
know it's not real acid does gives you a
little push cuz you'll see this glass
going wobble wobble wobble wobble wobble
and you're like I know that's not moving
but I do see that so you're not kind of
digging yeah and you relax your
inhibitions your suspension of belief
just relaxes and it encourages you to
here three breathing because you're like
I think I and everyone around you is
like oh my god and so you just go with
that I know you never had a bad trip I
did know later in life once I started to
learn more about the anxieties and the
dark parts of the world I think acid was
a great thing to do when you're young
when you're old you know about bills you
know about poverty you know about the
famine you know about death and it's all
you see and it's like an acid amplifies
that if you're if you're stressed out in
life or anxious in life and you try and
take a drug like that to escape it it's
not it's gonna backfire it's gonna
enhance that so how did the call with
the parents go at that point you were
you'd even though you were hearing trees
breeze I was hearing treated where you
were like I'm gonna drop out of college
this is gonna be great I I knew I was
gonna drop out cause I was excited about
it I didn't like failing you know I
didn't like doing someone wasn't good at
night I did feel stupid about myself
just for just
not succeeding at something that I
probably could if I put my mind to it so
I think I think my dad called me I was
like hey I'm dropping a school I think
did we just made the conversation very
brief very confident and very this is
just what's happening and I think my dad
understood my dad I think dropped out of
school at one point and went back later
my dad took charge of his own life he
enlisted in Vietnam which I was like
that's that it's always been wild to me
and I've always kind of admired that so
he I think he got it I think they both
got it that was one thing I'm grateful
my parents for they never really you
know when I was 31 I was like hey can I
borrow 200 bucks
my mattress from the garbage needs a pad
because I was sleeping on a mattress
that I found in the garbage right even
up until dr. Seuss versus William
Shakespeare was released I was still
sleeping on a mattress that I found in
the garbage which I always think this
morning well because at that point it
gets you had it you're sleeping on I was
sleeping on it I had it I don't mean it
ain't broke exactly so I just drop out
of school flat and I went out but then I
also dropped out of that and went back
to the the school my school town and I
worked at an Applebee's you dropped out
of the improv
yeah I didn't feel it I didn't feel like
it was going in the right direction and
that's something I yeah I think I
mentioned I have a good inner sense of
like this ain't gonna work I'm out yeah
and sometimes you got to do that and so
I was out and I went back to school
there was a girlfriend there there were
friends there we and I learned how to
sing and I learned how to make music but
you didn't reenroll no no I worked at
Applebee's okay
that was also good I let me turn it back
to this I went back to that town it was
a cool town cool college town and we
hung out and I used to sit it literally
sounds like a dream to me but it was my
life for a while we I've just meet up
with this group people sit in a field
and like drink a little bit smoke a
little bit and make up songs and I would
sing with this this guy Greg who taught
me how to harmonize and taught me we
would sit and do these vocal exercises
where you're like all right let's hit
the same pitch and then you go down just
a little bit and we'll hear it warble
and I feel it in your bones that that
note is is not right but it's what we're
doing so it is right
we're meaning to do it was meaning to do
and I started to learn about harmony
session and I started to learn about
like all this stuff and just okay and I
started to really improvise songs and
like seeing boldly and and not know what
I was gonna sing next but it didn't
matter because it was like it had
momentum and people were laughing and my
girlfriend the time at this great laughs
and she loved to listen to music and it
was just a great time in my life and
then I left it all and moved to Chicago
to to follow another dream what was this
dream the Chicago's like the mecca of
improv comedy okay and a friend to a
couple of friends of mine who had
written songs about leaving the cast of
our college improv show had gone out and
they were like laying the foundation of
moving to Chicago so the three people
that that we were running that improv
show sort of the creative directors all
three of us moved out to Chicago
together got an apartment together
and we all just started hitting the
ground on the improv scene in Chicago
and joined improv Olympic and and just
started pursuing that and then that
became our world and I was I was working
at a restaurant during the day lunch
shifts and just doing improv seven
nights a week you know and while you
were doing that what was the the goal
what were you trying to con no idea I
was just aimlessly following this thing
in my head that Ben Houser told me in
high school that I had to be on TV or
else I'd let him down and he was like my
best friend at the time and and he him
and I for some reason my friendship with
him erased that that feeling always had
a like feeling left out and feeling like
I didn't really connect with male
friends my best friend as a kid
it's just weird there's something weird
in there that I I haven't even quite
figured out but I felt just weird and
alienated and with this friendship I
felt not like that and so it was always
in my head too did not let him down and
so I had to just keep talking I'm just
keeping going people go in a second city
to do comedy I gotta go people are there
performing on Thursday night I gotta go
I got a who knows on me you know who
everything's possible I have to do it
and so I was always doing it and how
long did this Chicago thing last until I
met Lloyd
I met Lloyd it was also out in Chicago
in the improv team he's my partner in
the rap Al's now Sheila and we met at a
party rapping on a back porch
and you met rapping alright back porch
at a party in Chicago yeah so he was
like doing a freestyle yeah there was a
freestyle circle going on and I and I
joined it and I had because of my
experience in college I've I had this
boldness to just write just say stuff
and I might not be able to get it to a
rhyme but if I sell it right it doesn't
matter you know if you go out with like
me I don't know I can't think of an
example now I'm so out of practice but I
just I I got a job with Lloyds touring
improv troupe and that's when I got my
first taste of getting money for doing
what I love and I was hooked I was like
I can't do anything but this this is
great and where where were the tours all
around the Midwest primarily at colleges
the NACA circuit and we would show up
some shows would be sold out not sold
cuz they're free tickets but a huge
audience like dying to see us love it
some audience would be a lunchroom in
Dubuque at noon
Oh in a cafeteria well but we'd have to
make them laugh for an hour and so we
did it now die on a Starbucks the Double
Shot and get out there bike yawol sees a
funny and and there was one show in
particular in Detroit where we were
opposite of McDonald's it was like
imagine just showing up and doing an
improv show in a McDonald's in the
McDonald in the McDonald's and it was my
favorite show ever
I had to Starbucks double shots and I
was like I'm gonna do this I'm gonna get
this crowd these are my black ladies at
the post office yeah this is the
grumpiest crowd they don't want to see
us they don't want to be here they don't
want us to make them laugh and I'm gonna
do it they won't eat Nuggets and that
was the spirit of the whole group it was
like we're gonna do this this is our job
we're getting paid for it work we have
to do this show so let's try our hardest
and you are you are singing songs no
songs no that was just there's a short
form improv so it's kind of like whose
line is it anyway just games wacky
characters just that kind of stuff just
getting in the audience's face flat you
know if somebody sneezes over there
this whole sketch is about this about a
sneeze if a you would use that french
fries those look delicious all six of us
will get around you talk about delicious
a little further and then everyone
starts to get like oh this is this is
about us this is real this is actually
happening these guys are not giving up
so we might as well listen and that just
built up my chop so much and Lloyd was
there on this tour that was Louise
company it was him and him in a group of
six guys started this company very
independent they were like this is
[ __ ] that nobody gets paid doing
improv
we're gonna watch can we get paid and so
they they got paid and they and they
went out and made their own way and uh
yeah and inspired me a lot and like you
were like all crammed into a van driving
around in to avange cracking jokes and
that was it
for help have a long year and a half I
did that and what year are we talking
about so we can kind of get a bearing ah
- mm - that's good 2002 2003 and I again
I'd kind of put down my guitar a little
bit and I was really focusing on on
comedy improv starting to do well
starting to get recognized and then I
got cast as Luke Skywalker in a Star
Wars musical spoof of course and that's
where was this that was at ImprovOlympic
upstairs guy named Jason chin it was
great directed it wrote it and this
musical director named Stephanie taught
me how to sing and got me there was no
microphone so I had to project oh wow
this booming voice I had to get it I had
to find it and with her found it and
that changed everything and then I
started playing open mics and I had one
funny song I wrote in high school about
a dildo and a cover of baby got back of
course uh-huh and I went to an open mic
and I played those two and people went
nuts sing us a little bit of the dildo
song you want the guitar to tune it
that's fine all right oh that one's in
tune over there the seagull the seagulls
in - yeah all right
he's like I asked him to sing this song
is his eyes are darting around like he's
he's three guitars it's awesome we've
never had a performance on your biscuits
uh I'm a few on the spy here
a lot two minute time so I would show up
in a room and I would look real innocent
still at hair at the time and I wouldn't
like I wouldn't know no one knew was
gonna do anything funny it's my tie it
might not even be funny anymore I look
at everyone and just like I'm gonna sing
a sweet song and then I build it up and
build other than also night just like
the dinosaur was replaced by the
alligator Daniel the boyfriend was
replaced by a vibrator little boy just
say little boy because I look like a
little kid I didn't start growing up
until about three years ago I mean this
is why and I yeah exactly I lived for
that moment that moment of you know I
build up noise built noise nothing gets
a room quieter than silence and just
before I start saying I go and everyone
will go and then I go vibrator and then
go and and that just changed my life
that experience I love touring with the
improv troupe but I was just a little
bit too selfish of a performer cuz I
loved it more when I was just I got to
conduct this room of energy and just
like get them all out get them all quiet
but I wanted to songs so that's right
right so this this guy came up he was
like man you gotta come back next week I
was great ya gotta play more songs and I
was like I don't know any more songs so
then I started writing songs and then I
just it was a time my life when I was
single and I was the only time in my
life on a single and I just that's all I
did
I just wrote I learned how to use Pro
Tools and I start going to open mics and
I found this one Wednesday nights at
coils tippling house and that's in
Chicago I went every Wednesday and
that's just where I workshop everything
and I just you know ten minutes you only
got 10 minutes so every time every week
I'd have to new songs and I became great
friends the bartender I'm still friends
of them still visit him his family
Minnesota sometimes so okay so how did
it go from this to the converse the
story you told us the beginning of
meeting Danny Diamond and then at this
world of YouTube opening up to you
because you said he introduced you to
cast them and yeah well I'd say there's
a little bit in between that
I did start to become a little
successful at that and I started touring
regionally I pulled back out of the
improv troupe because again I felt it's
getting a little emotionally intense the
guys that some of the relationships were
combusting a little bit I was like I'm
out I'm gonna focus on music I got up
I'll put a band together
I met this girl played drums for me we
ended up dating I met this guy I play
bass for me and we put a little
three-piece together and we would tour
and play shows with these funny songs I
had about 15 of them at that point and I
just I stopped myself I put this I put
this invisible barrier on myself I never
really strived to become a real success
and I don't know why and I don't know
what it did I I don't I just was either
stupid or lazy or not focused or I had
nobody helping me the right kind of way
I had guys help me get shows and stuff
and there there was a guy in England who
kept me going for years after I would
have given up because I would go to
England and those audiences were awesome
but people just stopped listening and I
expected I did I expected the world to
give it to me
and I didn't realize that I had to get
it and so by the time you know I did
that for eight years and I played every
every every place you can I used to play
an airplane hangar and they would pay me
in parachute jumps like I got to skydive
for free because I played the night
before I've actually played in for
airplane hangars oh you're like a
skydiving fiend or something no this is
a good market it's a good market there I
used to play the acoustics are great the
acoustics are great and that the the
guys are wild they have a high you know
my show got racy got raunchy it got real
raunchy and like my mom didn't like any
of my music and I shouldn't care about
that but I know somewhere in the back of
my underdeveloped brain I did and I just
I toured on that and I became this I had
a sweet face and a really dirty mouth
and a really shocking mouth and I would
say anything about anybody like what was
the barrace estate you went in one of
these songs I mean I used it as sexual
therapy for my own issues of sexuality
and I just I would talk about everything
I would talk about you know if I was
having trouble with a girl in bed I
would sing I write a song about it
graphically and you know I wrote a song
called the mystery of the clitoris and
it was this long like it could be
helpful it
I think it was a little bit helpful I
think I'd sex education I did my own
therapy for myself and I shared it with
people and I think it made everybody
feel comfortable is like this guy's
talking about having troubles keeping an
erection and I felt like that before
I don't why do I have to why can't we
talk about it why can't we laugh about
it and I think it did appeal to a
certain cross-section of people but I
was stuck in bars and I was stuck on
money and that's what was stupid that
was part of what I did it so there
wasn't like you said there was this
invisible barrier against success that
you can't really pinpoint we was it that
okay well I don't know exactly what the
next step I didn't know the next step
and I was always trying to pay the bills
I would take the gig that paid 600 bucks
to play for 300 people that don't care
at a bar in a suburb rather than like
the intimate listening room weren't
warning and my fans would show up and
really I got to grow as a performer I
was always just I was just entertaining
groups I was better at audiences never
seen me before you were following the
money but the money was small money was
small limited and I wasn't developing a
following in the I wasn't playing - if I
wasn't I wasn't doing enough for the
people that follow me to be honest I was
I was I was putting them in places with
a hundred other people who didn't care
and after eight years of this yeah you
kind of get to a point where like you
said earlier your girlfriend at the time
is like what are you what am i doing do
we yeah cuz you're just barely getting
by if you go out and play gigs you know
you can go to tour England and I could
make 2,000 bucks come home but it
doesn't go anywhere it doesn't have real
growth and like like I said I now I'm
realizing I just didn't do enough for my
fans I didn't do enough for the people
who supported me so how low did it get
for you I mean I played a Christmas
party at a pie lotty's instructor's
living room and she specialized in
senior Pilates and I played an acoustic
set in the corner of a living room and
this was probably about four months
before you guys met me were they doing
Pilates at the time no was there
Christmas celebration and they were
older people seventy tonight and you
were singing about the clitoris I was I
I sang I did instrumentals of those
songs so I can amuse myself I was like
if I was singing these words and I sang
how much is that doggie in the window
like three times
they love that what they loved it oh
yeah they did I say right low point I
get it low point but I still play music
yeah it was 200 bucks you know and I was
still doing it I was doing every Monday
night at a bar in Playa del Rey I was
doing every Tuesday night at a bar in
Long Beach I was out here I got a job at
break com2 right so what what
necessitate okay why don't move Delia
cuz I gave I was like should I Chicago
was a great place to give up on your
dreams and it was a great place to find
your dreams and then eventually give up
on them and it it just wasn't there
aren't that kind of those kind of people
Danny doesn't live in Chicago you know
he lives in LA you guys don't live in
Chicago you live in LA now and I was I
was I needed somebody I needed somebody
to help me and there was a guy in
England there was a guy in Chicago was
helping me book shows and it was great
this guy in England that was really
helping me so I thought about moving to
England I almost got married to this guy
so I could stay in England we were gonna
we were so close we I mean we didn't
have an intimate relationship but we
were like let's get married just for the
legal for the legal Thanks close enough
we'll sell tickets to the wedding it'll
be packed
we were we were local we were local he
made me a local hero he almost had a
fake gay mayor Saturday gay marriage
that is absolutely a step and I'm
talking we researched it we looked into
it and the I England kept me going
because American audiences their
attention strangers
wasn't great and I like I said I was I
was not really paying attention that
people really wanted me see me I was
just trying to entertain mass because
that's where the money was and so in
England they just listen you put a sign
out says live music tonight people like
let's go listen and a guy my favorite
story about England guy came up to me
you know didn't really enjoy your music
I'd like to buy you a beer
cheers for playing it's a fair trade-off
it was great he listened the whole time
clapped after every song didn't doesn't
really like what you do but really
really proud of you for doing it I'd
like to buy you a pint that doesn't
happen here doesn't happen
they'll start playing darts and and that
was one thing that I kept in my arsenal
somebody stopped listening
I would shred them I would as soon as
somebody wasn't paying attention I'll
just slowly start singing about their
hair and their glasses until the people
around them back singing about this
cannot be a coincidence because he just
said blue hair and that guy has blue
hair and a turtleneck and put out sing
it as if it was this written song you
know I wouldn't really look at the guy
and he would have chord structure and
melody and and people would start
giggling it's like reverse heckling
exactly prob so I would heckle the
audience and that was only that only
became my staple and that's not a great
way to to grow if I have to be an
adverse situation to thrive right I hit
the wall on what I can do in entertain
bars and but you made a last-minute
decision it sounds like to not do the
fake gay marriage in England they gave
me to LA yeah I moved to LA uh uh a girl
I was dating at the time kind of
encouraged me to get out of Chicago I've
always been I've always I've always had
my own issues underdeveloped as a as a
man and so I've always leaned on girls
to make me whole did she say I'll come
out here with you yeah yeah she said you
should go not you're hitting walls here
she also she said we should go yeah well
she said she didn't want to go oh she
didn't want to go and this is like 2010
yeah 2009 maybe mm mm okay so I I did
that music thing and I kept writing
songs I kept trying to do albums I got a
new drummer or a different drummer and I
just I just never was applying myself as
much as I could and that was just that
and I was also I was limiting myself by
every song I had had an f-bomb in it
every song I had and I didn't know how
to write clever stuff I didn't have the
guts to do it I didn't have the guts to
explore deeper emotions again like I
used to because he can't do that in
front of a crowded noisy bar in
Wisconsin you can't like explore
subtlety of humor and so that's why when
I started singing on YouTube because
they're listening the whole time
nobody's heckling you nobody's coughing
the attention is focused I was able to
start exploring that again and in
reawakened my creative energy
so did you start making YouTube videos
first or meet Danny first it's tough
call I don't know how did you meet Danny
I met Danny cuz I got a cousland they
were hiring writers and I I submitted as
a sketch writer and I had the worst
sketches ever but I had made the fine
brothers a fine brothers were head
writer station were hiring write ups and
I submitted sketches I had made that
first picture song just cuz I was trying
to figure out what to do I didn't know I
was your first youtube video was it
pictures no I actually had a hit viral
video 2006 I had a song called 57 got
500,000 views in 2006 and I didn't I had
100 subscribers I had no idea what to do
with it I didn't I was a stupid idiot I
look back at I've like that was your
chance and you just didn't realize you
didn't capitalize and you didn't sit
down and make another video instead you
watch bo burnham videos and got jealous
and that's so stupid
that's so stupid to look at something
big why our night wasn't happening to me
and and the answer was in front of me
all along it's like why aren't I doing
that and that's what I just did just
dawned on me
so Lloyd had a connection with the
station they were looking for writers he
has it because of the comedy circuit has
a comedy circuit yeah and Lloyd's just
the type of guy that if he sees
something can help somebody else he's
gonna pass him along and he saw that and
I was I got fired from break I was there
I was brought on to make original music
content and I got fired and I love that
why'd you get fired
cuz I wanted to make good things so you
told them that the things they were
asking you makes don't know I just we
just didn't work out we did we did I
shouldn't have said that we did we had
different sensibilities okay no no I
don't know but I loved it and it was
that was that was good for me to just to
fail so hard to be at such a low point
when I did meet Danny to be so desperate
so how we were working for break make it
writing songs for other people or for
writing songs ready sketches no for
break just as a writer yeah I went in
front of a camera nope I was writing and
I wrote I wrote a song called Santa's a
gangster and I was like we should
I got they wanted me to make a Christmas
video I was like dude this is good trust
me and there wasn't it
so I did it and I made it
and I made it with Lloyd and I had that
YouTube video and I a picture song and
when I submitted to the fine brothers to
be a writer my sketches were terrible
but they happen to look at my youtube
channel they were like you can write
songs yeah we should get you to write
songs for Dave days and that's what I'm
originally in my that's in my original
meeting that was like what I was gonna
do was write songs for other people and
that's what I did for a while and it was
it was it was great but I hit I was got
hired to write ten songs at $100 a song
to write record produce the big bucks
doing all that that was to me at the
time is awesome yeah cuz I mean we you
were flat broke you said oh five broke
and I got a check for a thousand bucks
and all I had to do was write writing
record ten songs which I was gonna do
anyway and I learned how to I've learned
how to make parodies I got off my high
horse and I was like I'm gonna learn how
to do this and during that course I you
know during that I learned more about
production and like alright how do I
make something sound like that on the
radio now I know it so what's one of the
songs you wrote for Dave days you said
yeah I didn't I didn't end up writing
any songs for Dave days but there was
there was that just I just remember that
conversation I had a management company
that was tied into the Improv Theater
here in LA so I was doing shows at The
Improv and I I remember one night I did
a show and I crushed it and it was great
and then the next morning I was
polishing silver we're at the restaurant
job I had and I got yelled at for not
doing it right and that I quit I was
like this is so stupid I can do that and
I'm getting yelled at for polishing
sporks wrong and like no offense to
anyone who polishes Forks but this is
not for me this is not what I should be
doing so I quit my job so I had no idea
offing and where does that leave me too
I was just desperate God somehow I don't
know that time gets a little murky
around that time because everything
happened so fast
I was super desperate it was my I saw it
as my last chance I was really about to
give up on everything then I got this I
got this gig delivering weed brownies
through my friend Corey who I haven't
talked to in ages and I hope I get to
talk to him again soon because I lost
his phone number so Corey if you're out
there
oh he's listening so I I just threw my
whole everything everything I've ever
known how to do ever I threw into making
videos and it was all I did okay and so
we covered at the beginning about you
know the conversation with Danny and
then the conceptualizing
the epic Rap Battles of History yeah
seeing that initial success following it
up and then all of a sudden you've got
this expectation yeah I freaked out I
got it I gotta keep coming up with a sad
nervous breakdown I got a nervous
breakdown yeah I turned off my phone I
chain him a phone number I didn't call
anyone
at what point how many battles in
started maybe about four or five battles
in oh wow I moved right there's another
guy missing from the story and I hope
I'm not just making it too boring and
full-on until is Dante who became my co
songwriting partner I never had you know
you guys have a songwriting partnership
I never I'd never had that before and I
just hadn't hadn't met the guy and I met
Dante and we you know we worked on that
shaycarl shaytards song together we
worked on Superman talks together and he
was just willing to go man we did 60
takes of that shaycarl shaytards song to
get one that worked from top to bottom
and he was just every tape he was like
all right do it again let's do it again
let's do it again
let's do it again let's do it again and
he was just right that was your writing
partner I was my writing partner and he
actually he called me to help him with
the project he was doing we wanted to
make music for a documentary about
hot-air balloons don't we all you know
and so maker started throwing more songs
at me and and been at maker through a
song of me that was that got me to go
out and visit Dante again he wanted us
to make something that sounded like Love
Hurts but wasn't Love Hurts and so we
did that we pulled this song out of our
asses and and we tracked it and we were
getting we were me and Dante we're
becoming tight musically and we would
record in his garage
out out in Pacoima and that's where we
did shaycarl and that's better huh and
then it's uh so all this stuff is
happening I'm just getting excited
people you know I did that song about
Shane his family he put it in his blog
all of a sudden I was at a 4th of July
party and I just my I used to get an
email every time I got a subscriber
uh-huh and all of a sudden all of a
sudden my whole life changed and I
changed on a blackberry and I just like
new subscriber news and then also nine
ten thousand people watching me so I
went from 150 people to ten thousand and
that's that was big to me and I knew
this is all I'm doing I cancelled every
gig I canceled everything I just and
Danny gave me the salary and I think
Danny Danny wanted to get me out of
writing and into being me I do know that
part of the reason I really freaked out
is because I got I got a level of
adoration an ADD ulation that I wasn't
ready for and I didn't feel good about
my sister's a nervous breakdown yeah I
didn't feel good about myself I didn't
feel like I deserved a 150 tweets every
morning saying I was really great I felt
awful my relationship was falling apart
my relationship with my brother had hit
some real like just had fallen apart
what do you mean my ELISA my brother
just hit because of some issues left in
me from my childhood I I just had a
falling out with my brother so I was
disconnected from him I was disconnected
I was pulling back from the whole world
as far as real interaction and just
hiding behind a keyboard and a camera
and I'm pulling back from the microphone
as I do it except that's how I felt I
just felt like I was behind this thing
and I didn't talk to people I I just I
edited also my own face every day and
that's just not good for you I did my
own voice through editing and and I took
out any part that I thought was weird I
took out any part where I thought I
looked weird or I thought I sounded
weird and that just it started taking
too long me is that why you are
sunglasses I wore sunglasses because
mystery guitar man wore some black and I
wore sunglasses because it was sunny the
day I was brought to drive the van to
Las Vegas on a maker trip maker had a
big brain deal in Las Vegas
that's where I met che met Qasim I was
wearing sunglasses that was my job I was
the driver and it was bright out and I
was in some videos and someone left a
comment that guy in a sunglass that guy
in the yellow and green sunglasses are
really funny who's he and that told me
who I was gonna be I was gonna be that
guy in the green yellow sunglasses
always and it made it easier for me to
look at the viewfinder instead of so I
could make sure I was always in the shop
do the shooting stuff myself and it just
it gave me a look
it gave me something so you weren't
hiding behind sunglasses and the process
was you were kind of
I mean the nice person that you now are
as a result of your interaction with
your audience I think so I think I just
I just grew up a little bit and and I
just took more emotional risks a little
more the breakdown yeah how far did the
breakdown go anyway what was this like
don't talk to me I'm not making any more
rap out of no all I did was work okay
all I did was work don't talk to me
about anything else I didn't I just I
just had no real connection with people
and I had no real connection with my
family and just like I freaked out on my
family I just had lost I turned off my
phone stop calling my friends and I
stopped I just I don't know what
happened I just freaked out I just
wasn't ready I was not ready to go from
150 subscribers to a million and a half
subscribers in like six months
but did you keep the inner circle intact
but Lloyd and Lauren - yeah Lloyd and
Dante yeah yeah yeah absolutely and did
they say hey we're worried about you
mm no because they're they're both I
mean Lloyd is his work obsessed designer
I think he was like welcome to the club
bro yeah a work is all that matters so
are you still there are you out of it I
don't know I think I'm much more
balanced the return to your phone back
on it started my phone back on I start
reaching out to people and I had some
apologies to go around I mended my
relation with my brother I think I
mentioned I was just talking to me today
so I the relationship that I'm in now
the personal relationship I'm in now
encouraged me to make amends and grow
more than like turn my back on everybody
and just focus on work yeah and also I
think I did it I did what I always
wanted my sir mix-a-lot and baby got
back was my career aspiration if I could
have one hit that everybody knows
forever forever I could just cruise on
that I could just like be that guy who
has that one hit and once I did that I
felt like Vader Hitler was that hit and
I did it again with like a couple more
rattles it became big hit I was like I'm
I did it I did what I said I have to do
I'm I'm done right so I just chill out
now I can I can I can look inward and
kind of develop myself as a person
because I spent 12 years doing nothing
but trying to get here and now I'm here
and I'm miserable
and that's so stupid because I have
everything I always thought
wanted why do i why do I go to Bed Bath
& Beyond to buy myself things to feel
better because I have money but I feel
terrible now it was so stupid so where
are you at now in that process what's
going on inside
Prime Minister nice Pete's head ah right
now I it's we made some videos that are
so cool it's so hard to keep up with
them it's so hard to keep up with what
we what we've already done and it's also
physically so taxing it's such a it's
such an obsession it becomes these songs
becomes such an obsession and the videos
become I know every frame and every tick
of every peek of everything and it just
it just loops over and over again in my
head as I try to get to sleep so I
started drinking too much to get to
sleep and it which obviously makes it
next morning you drink too much coffee
and then just this wound up thing and
it's just right now I feel good cuz I
think we just put out one that is of the
of the level of where we wanted to be
which we just put out Michael Jordan
versus Muhammad Ali we're talking about
a little bit and I was like this is this
is this is it I'm so proud of this I
like it's hard it's hard to it's hard to
continue because I don't want it to suck
ever and it's because it can be so it
can be so cool that we can just keep
working on it until it gets there I
don't know it's hard so it's just this
building pressure of it's got to be as
good or better than the last one yeah
yeah well and it's sort of the you know
it's the we have a little taste of this
just having a YouTube channel and making
a rank on YouTube not having that one
thing though but there is this the
indefinite never-ending season of epic
rap battle history like that doesn't
that you know that's not how the world
ever worked in entertainment right there
was a gatekeeper who gave you another
season there was a company that financed
another movie you know but I guess the
TV series is a better thing to use as a
comparison because it was the same thing
but they just never last I mean you know
the best shows
cancelled right right right but now
you're the gatekeeper right for epic Rap
Battles of History and you can just go
on indefinitely that's it's just a weird
place to be and like you know from a
psychological perspective you're kind of
establishing what the psychology of that
situation is because you're one of the
only people that has that to experience
you can't have a mentor there's nobody
who did this right in 1975 I had a lot
of mentors getting into it and now we're
all I think all those mentors and me are
all like I don't know man I don't know
how this works you know I I really
admire grey and and still do and and he
I think he's easiness he's in a similar
place of like I did it I became the
number one subscribed YouTube channel
now what do I do mm-hm and it's like I
could do this forever I want to do other
things he's making a movie he's doing
other things and I I don't want to what
I admire about you guys and when you do
is that you have such a great
relationship with your audience and
you're so you're so trustworthy with
them you say you're gonna do something
you do it I feel like I just let my down
let my audience down over and over again
I feel like my core audience who really
cares about the music that I make and
they know what my dog's name is hmm I
haven't been there for them or in that
audience performer relationship since I
started doing the rap battles again it's
I just can't I can't I was faking it for
a while that was another thing that was
bad for me was I would be miserable put
on a very happy face make a very happy
video edit it so it felt great and we're
talking your second channel yeah like
your Monday show yeah exactly
vlog yeah and based and I love doing
that stuff and it's I love the
connection and it got that connection
got me through everything it became an
that became my form of therapy but it's
it's it's not it's not healthy so if
there's a sense that where you're at
right now is not sustainable so that's
what I'm hearing you kind of say yeah
what where where do you think you go
from here I have no idea you know I'm
I'm currently like I'm currently in a
contract to make a lot more rap battles
and I'm
kind of in a contract with myself to
make a lot more rap battles but I'm
definitely in a contract with with a
company to make a lot more rap battles
or that they're gonna be made and and
III could sometimes I get tempted and
wonder about like stepping away from
them more but I feel such an emotional
connection to them I feel like they're
my babies and there are a lot of
people's babies we all there's a lot of
us at work on them I'm not the only
person works on them but I I do I have a
real deep personal connection to them
and the way they get come out so you're
not willing you're not able to shift
your gaze from that I don't think so I
don't think I don't I think I just care
about them too much to let them go a
different direction and I'm and I'm just
I don't that's maybe my own problem that
I'm enough trust in people but it's
tough it's tough call I don't know what
I think I'm just gonna keep going so you
find yourself staying up all hours of
the night learn teaching yourself After
Effects
well I'm trying to catch up our After
Effects guy's a wizard but he's only one
he's only one guy right and we we have
had people we did we a very valuable
member of our crew I don't know if I
mentioned this on the show already went
it went to Saturday Night Live yeah our
director and main editor went and he was
like he's the guy who made Rap Battles
look the way they did he made that logo
I was there with him and I was like can
you move that part a little higher yeah
but but he he he he nailed it and he was
he's gifted he's a gifted guy and to
anytime you try and you know replace
that it's gonna be a challenge and so it
is I learned from him I know how to do
what he does effortlessly I know how to
do through a great deal of effort and me
and the rest of our editing team are I
think we just got to a place there was
three of us edited Michael Jordan Merce
Muhammad Ali and I think we it's as good
as anything we ever made with Dave and
that we're really proud of that our
after effects guy has grown to great
lengths but then it's just to having
more people in there working on it is
always better so from a so how does all
this apply on a on a personal front you
know things fell apart with your family
at some point are you are you setting
yourself up
for a second breakdown no that's what I
want I want to avoid that at all costs
I don't think I'll ever get there again
I think you know I'm just because I'm
aware of it being possible I'm never
gonna get there I'm not I can't I worked
myself too hard before and I gave up my
humanity and I can't do that anymore I
just don't want to do that anymore I'd
rather work on stunt work right and
maybe work a little healthier and learn
from you guys how how to sustain an
operation in a way that doesn't
sacrifice your family I could you guys
have kids I could never I could not
possibly even begin to have a child
right now and and and it's something I
want to do with my life at some point so
I got to figure how to get well it will
change things so that's the thing you
know sometimes just having the kid it's
like oh okay well I've got to make some
adjustments now I'm not saying you
should have a kid to make my little
better right I'm just saying that you
know I'm not saying anything you do
whatever you want to do but if you have
a kid it just it it did it for a forces
change yes we're not saying have a kid
to make your life better but have a kid
and put it in the line of fire no he's
not saying that okay
well let's bring it back in closing -
Ben what's his name your your friend
dozer Ben Hauser and he lives in South
Korea now you keep in touch with Ben not
as much as I do in my head so in your
head what do you think Ben is saying I
think he's proud of me it's kind of
funny how we're talking about it like
he's like he's a dead relative
no I what do you think Ben is he's Saint
looking down from heaven I think he I
think he's proud of me and I feel like
I've satisfied that part that part of my
life journey and now it's exciting
because I'm I have a reputation I have a
body of work that's really good and I
can and I have some money and I could I
can I know how to do things right now
and so I could I could put that energy
into into another project in the future
when when the epigraph of the history
does reach its conclusion which it has
to someday I'm excited about the rest of
my life because I don't know what I'm
gonna do I might just raise chickens
but I'm gonna raise good chickens and
you have Snoop Dogg's cellphone number I
don't have Snoop Dogg's cell phone
number but I know the dude yeah yeah you
can get into almost cool we're cool
in Snooper cool and that that could that
could last you a few years just that
Yeah right just and the amount of things
I've gotten to do I'm so grateful that's
why it's so hard to feel down cuz I'm so
lucky and I'm so grateful that it's so
stupid to not feel good and but
sometimes I just need to take a step
back and talk to people sometimes you
got to shake somebody's hand to remember
that there's actually human interaction
in the world that he's not through a
computer but we thank you for taking the
time to talk to us now you need to sign
the round table of demonstrating and
that was our conversation with nice
Peter nice pete shook off shook off
prime minister pete nice you you you
remember prime minister pete nice yeah
third base he was not the guy with the
cane he was what no he the guy with the
cane he wasn't the big guy right he was
the slick guy with the slick pair the
shorter yeah did have a cane he kind of
wrapped like this kinda okay yeah yeah
the thing that surprised me about Pete
was he wasn't always nice I mean really
like I told him we've had conversations
after talking with Pete and the takeaway
is always this guy is so nice and that's
why they call him nice Peter yeah but
that was that's what we thought it's
funny that that's not the case I yeah I
I was convinced that that's what he was
gonna tell me well I just had this
reputation of being really nice actually
he had the reputation from his stand-up
musical improv type approach of being
mean professionally mean and I mean the
way he presented it to us was the
Internet and his complimentary audience
gave him the confidence to be who he
really is
which is a nice guy well as opposed to a
stage act in it well because I mean I
think you know not that not that being
an Internet comedian versus being a
stand-up comedian is is necess
easier one it's not necessarily easier
than the other I don't think I think
that one is just more you know you more
demanding of people's attention you have
to say okay this guy is actively
heckling me or turning my back to him so
I've got to point this out in order to
gain control like we don't have to worry
about the person who's thinking negative
things about us during you know while
they're listening to this or watching a
internet video because right now it's
happening I'm not going to respond to
you sir they're in the blue shirt yes
you listening to ear biscuits right now
you're lying in your bed right now
you're about to go to sleep you're about
to nod off yes you with the brown hair
and the blue shirt you're a jerk why are
you sleeping in a blue shirt you should
be sleeping in pajamas you look like
nothing Punk
I'll wake up and finish listening to see
you were a real man you'd be sleeping in
the nude
it does attest it well that is also true
but that doesn't really work you know
he's singling somebody out yeah I mean
you that people just click away yeah
they're like I'm not the guy in the blue
shirt you can't even make fun of them as
they're clicking away because it
happened so quickly I mean it happens in
the instance that you're gonna click the
way already they're gone there they go
they're gone by they're gone what you
see but but you're still here and you're
the only one that really matters for
this ear biscuit so I mean Pete is truly
a nice guy I mean after we we stopped
the recording he was going through
people that he wished he would have
shouted out I wish I would have said
that I was influenced by the fine
brothers to to always give him a best
and to be excellent did I mention them
because I meant to and you know he's
extremely grateful and humble and I it's
not an act it is who he really is so I
think it's great that the Internet
audience allowed him to become the real
him and still be as funny and
entertaining as he has but not have to
to deal with the hecklers and be shaped
by that right so why don't you air
biscuit ears I'm gonna keep trying to
sell that by the way keep you do the
nice thing go over to nice peter's
channel is epic Rap Battles Channel
maybe it's Twitter whatever you want to
do go telling you enjoyed his ear
biscuit
and you wanted to keep being nice and
keep making rap back yeah his Twitter is
twitter.com slash you guessed it nice
Peter let them know yeah and another in
a brisket coming your way very soon
hashtag ear biscuits I think we're
skipping a week for the holidays that's
the recipe with the family and then
we'll be back two weeks from now so we
won't be gone that long
don't you worry happy holidays stay warm
[Music]
[Music]